put out a call to say if you have a
relationship question one call will you
help one of our listeners let's do it
yeah so I'm not I know you take them on
Zoom but we have one one call coming in
if you could bring in a call no I got
the number so that I can call oh you
call it okay and uh here we
go and feel free Natalie to also turn
your volume up for to uh help out look
at hello hello
um who is this hey uh this is Derek
Derek um we put out a call on social
media that if you had a question about
relationships we have uh Nick V here uh
oh gosh yeah Nick and also wa wait wait
dude oh I'm sorry what what did you say
I love the vile files his podcast oh I
love that thank you thank you and
Natalie his fiance is also so here and
uh you could pose a question and
hopefully they can help you with your
relationship yeah Nick um are you in a
relationship I am I'm in I've been in a
relationship um super happy with this
girl for the last three years and I'm
honestly I think I'm planning on asking
her to marry me in the next few months
wow um congrats I have so
I I don't know this got kind of
embarrassing but I uh I'm I'm on only
fans a lot um and I recently won a
contest I don't know if you're familiar
with the only fans uh [__] a fan contest
oh wait wait
wait is this real did you win I paid a
lot of money what is that I don't I'm
not familiar with that what is that so I
follow this girl on only fans she's
super hot uh she recently said whoever
donates the most for the last month she
would agree to have J is this a
joke is this a
joke no this is it's pretty common with
the only fans Community it's kind of
blown up on the internet I didn't think
it was real I didn't I I kind of entered
it as a joke okay but how much money did
you spend that's the question
uh I kind of don't want to say it's more
than you should spend on an engagement
ring is it more than a
thousand uh a lot more than a thousand
does your will you plan on spending this
much on your engaging
ring uh yeah no I mean the ring I well I
the ring I want to did a nice one but
now I'm kind of in a pickle because I
honestly you spent you spent that money
I'm in a pickle so my question to you
Nick is how how do I tell
my what would I say to let my future
fiance be okay with me doing this [__] a
fan you want to do it I I don't think I
can help you buddy I mean I you're
asking me to figure out how to position
this in a way that she's going to be
okay with it no I mean what is there
anything that you think of that I could
say to her that to to be like hey this
is a once- in a-lifetime Opportunity
never going to have this again in my
life this is something well that's not
true you can donate money again well
this is people have get of Ja free cards
to their reality stars for their mental
health people get have like those get
out of jail free cards where they have
one
person yeah whatever it is what do you
think Natalie well for
I'm I'm I'm just a little I'm a little
stumped so you you want to [__] this
only fans girl but you also still want
to keep your
girlfriend yes what is there anything
that you could think of that I could how
do I even bring this up that's a great
question does he bring it up does he
just go ahead and do it and then no
no yeah I mean listen you once in a
lifetime I mean this you saw this girl
you would I mean if I'm like
it's the fact that you paid whatever
amount of money you know like it's not
like but the damage has almost been done
in that regard you know I've got friends
who spend way more money on only fans
than I do okay well good for you does
she even does she even know you're on
only
fans um I think she's yeah I don't I
don't think she knows exactly what it is
but yeah she's knows I'm on it did you
tell her you won cuz maybe she'll be
excited that she's getting married to a
winner he's a winner this one's a
winner what what conversations have you
had with your partner about any any kind
of
non-traditional uh relationship
activities like polyamorous or open
relation thre some once but she turned
me down she turned you down so we're
already off to a okay
so doesn't sound like she's think it was
because it was with her cousin
oh you're lying whatever like four not
not is this real yeah well yes I don't
know if he's [__] with us but that is
something
um I yeah I don't unfortunately I I
think um I think you should just be
honest with her about the money and go
from there I don't think I can offer you
any words of wisdom and how to kind of
uh convince your partner to be okay with
something they probably aren't going to
be okay pay with just like an ice
breaker just an ice breaker something
what are you talking about I don't know
what you mean like how to even bring it
up is that what you're asking I because
I haven't I haven't brought it up yet
yeah yeah I just don't even know where
to start I spent a ton of money that
would otherwise go to our
wedding that's a thing you're like and
in return I get to cheat on
you but it's well technically wouldn't
be cheating if he he is he does want to
be he wants to tell her so I guess
credit there credit would you still do
it if she said no yeah great question
are you is this are you are you willing
to ask for permission but also willing
to ask for
forgiveness I I I want yes I mean I want
to bring it out it's because you know I
mean me and my hopefully future fiance
like we we don't have a emphasis on the
hopeful only fans girl is promising me
things that are I mean she says she
wants to dress up like the big bad wolf
and blow my house down I mean again if
you saw but you paid for her to say that
yeah yeah it doesn't mean it doesn't
have the same you're not actually going
to do that you just paid her for well so
maybe you know what okay well good luck
buddy was there any help did we learn
anything I don't yeah I think next time
next time I have next time well yeah I
guess I don't know it's just uh you got
to be upfront from the get you know if
you're going to do something where you
think there's a good chance he might not
be okay with it it it's hard to get them
to sign off on said thing when you tell
them halfway through the thing that you
you've already of you need to say you
need to say honey I am thinking of
entering a a [__] Contest no no it needs
to start with honey I'm thinking of
downloading only fans and know goes oh
yeah well she he she knows he's on only
fans but she doesn't know what it is oh
she doesn't know what it is according to
right Derek she does no she doesn't know
she doesn't know it's basically here
what I would say you should say you
didn't know also you didn't know look I
didn't know I won you thought it was the
threads the the threads the thread I
thought it was the threads yes you could
[__] somebody on threads too less than
$10,000
hello just 10 just what just what just
over 10 just over over under under just
under 10 okay oh my god um well what I
would say is get off the phone now and
go get a
job yeah go get money it sounds like
he's thank you for your call Derek and
uh thank you sorry we couldn't help you
out I think that was helpful it was
thank you guys love you Nick love you
Howe all right bye bye bye oh look at I
didn't know
who knew anyway I like I I love to get
interesting calls but you really
trumped anything we've ever done in the
v files I wonder if they'll ever get
over him wanting to [__] her fourth
[Music]
cousin